Batman Gandalf
Batman how you landed on my back man I'm
Batman
No
everyone this is Randolph here I have
Jonathan Smith from TT games and we're
sitting down about to play all they go
down mention they're just out real soon
and welcome Jonathan oh it's a great
pleasure to be here it's exciting days
the first time I've been able to play
through Lego dimensions together then
what we're actually not seeing right now
is there's a portal in front of us and a
whole load of basically Lego toys
can you talk us through what we're going
to be doing you sure so the game brings
your toys to life so we sell Lego
figures in a starter pack this is what
the starter pack sounds like I can't
show you it's a big box it's full of
bricks also gonna do is we're gonna
build that toy paper and the lights up
this is also full of minifigure
characters we've got in here Batman
wildstar from the lego movie Gandalf as
well vehicles the Batmobile is in here
and then those characters are going to
go on an adventure through the game and
when we place the characters on the toy
pad they come to life on the game we can
control them so what you can see on the
screen from the start is just to take
some of the different characters that
you can play in Lego dimensions we mix
up all the different Lego worlds so this
has never been done before this isn't
the game just set in one dimension this
is like other mentions and that means
that Gandalf the Rings is gonna back you
through the adventure right alongside
Batman and there are loads of extra
characters you can put in from anyway
your imagination can go and people have
been really surprised by the diversity
of different worlds and characters we've
been able to bring into the game we've
had incredible reaction to all the
different worlds that we've got out here
but in particular there are some fan
favorites like ghostbusters like Back to
the Future like Doctor Who where we've
had the quests over many years I've been
working on like against for more than 10
years work since the very first Lego
Star Wars and over the years we've
always go and we say what Lego games you
want to see and there's some that had
come up again again with
always been able to sit well with
unfortunate or not able to do that and
now for the first time all our dreams
have come true this is what we've been
building up to and everything we want to
put in one game altogether a lot so tell
me about the story here what's happening
with Robbie right now he's getting
sucked into a portal it's a that's right
poor Robin there in Gotham City in the
DC Universe dimension has just been
sucked into a rift now these rifts have
been opened up by the villain who's
amazingly played by Gary Oldman and they
take flit then the rifts opening up in
all the different Lego dimensions so
we've started off in Gotham City with
Batman and we could put gandalf onto the
tripod then we're gonna go to another
lego dimension here this is Lord of the
Rings dimension and you'll see there's
different character is going to be
sucked through the rift here because our
villain Lord Vortech is trying to get
the prime elements from the different
lego dimensions so he's trying to get
the ruby slippers from Wizard of Oz
world he's trying to get the cake and
here is trying to get the one ring from
Lord of the Rings world and what that
means with all these different
dimensions in play is that we can mix
them up so Gandalf unfortunately now is
is plummeting towards the Balrog or what
you don't see in the movie is the rift
open up and here comes the Batmobile and
now it's gonna be Gandalf and Batman
against the Balrog and this is this is
just a tear for taste of the mash-up
they're mixing together these different
dimensions that the story in this game
is going to take you through it's
supposed to mean we're gonna same to
right having all these different
characters interact with each other just
the most fun thing and you'll see you
know the opportunity for jokes as
characters meet different versions of
the cells or yeah nod some wings but
we've got actors who perhaps play
multiple cattle but Chris Pratt for
example the place both Emmett in the
lego movie and of course Owen in
Jurassic world only that wouldn't as
characters meet each other those really
funny exchanges that they can have with
each other
do you sort of have to be extra careful
when you're mixing so many sort of
franchises together like other certain
things that you can't you just can't
have Gandalf doing or you know there's
some things of Batman's in the lab
because we're in our Legos I mentioned
anything is possible you know there
should be no limits on creativity it's
just the same as when children play with
the bricks don't forget you know this is
where this is where we're coming from
and there's no one in the room to
prevent you from mixing up your
characters when you're playing in your
bedroom so it should be the same in the
video games
so we're here in Frankfurt on we're
going to start our adventure now by
placing three style of pac-man adventure
characters onto the toy pad and we'll
see them appear through the Gateway and
that's Batman go and off world style and
you'll also get the Batmobile in the
starter kit is that right that's right
and then the extra characters that you
can buy will unlock access to adventure
hub spaces which we'll play in a minute
we'll look toward try some of the
different character as well is just
giving you like ridiculous things you
can do in the levels yes so let's talk
about that was obviously the main
narrative which you know we're seeing
the cutscene over now you mentioned
adventure worlds can you explain what
that is so Anna there's the main games
got 14 levels through the story each one
taking you to a different lego dimension
and that's all completely playable where
the three characters you get in the
starter pack you can get all the
trophies in the game you can finish the
story with those three characters on
that one vehicle the Batmobile but there
are additional collectible characters of
vehicles and you can add to enhance your
collection and give you more options and
if you were to drop when I'm on if I
let's just drop someone in now who do
you want to see I've gotta leave it up
to you let's see we have we have a whole
range of um characters in front of me
here let's go for Homer Simpson Homer
since I have not seen Homer in action
yet so you just drop him on place them
on the pad and they immediately appears
in the game how many can you have at any
one time 7 X mm so there's plenty of
room on that power for different
characters and that includes vehicles
and various different accessories as
well and obviously you know we're
looking at a little bit of
play now so this looks like so the
classic Lego game playing which is each
of the characters has their own unique
sort of like abilities and moves around
oh that's right so switching between the
different characters has we've always
been a part of our Lego games and
there's that there's this the stuff that
you would find familiar hey we're
picking up these Lego studs we're going
to be searching for and collecting gold
bricks and red bricks and we'll be
solving puzzles by using it here's
gandalf some magic they're getting the
LEGO bricks down we're going to use to
build the Gateway but there are also
loads loads of new functions and
features as well that the new characters
have if you switch to present let's
switch to Homer now and we'll just see
one of his abilities that he can do when
he drinks his Cola they're amazing belch
power will break or you can go into evil
angry Homer as well
Omar and there was you to stomp through
the levels like a giant so there's loads
of value in each different characters as
well as they're either distinctive
personalities animations and voices and
as always to you know to get to
different puzzles and challenges in the
game you'll have to use a mix and match
and spin characters abilities in order
to congresso than not just the different
character abilities now that's that's
cool we've had in previous look again
but now you also use the toy pack almost
like I want like another game controller
because it's the lighting up and it's
giving you the options to move the
characters around physically there are
times in the games where you have to
move them in order to like evade an
attack for example or to be able to do a
special kind of build and or to solve
new puzzles that we've put with new
completely new features and with the new
Keystone features that are there on the
type I which will show you as we
progress through a little bit more
so what we're gonna do is we're building
the Gateway here now we've got wyldstyle
using some of her abilities which
includes being able to jump coolly
between these two walls she's gonna then
get up to the top here and smash down
some more bricks so that we can create
the collection of bricks we need to
actually build the Lego gate words gonna
take us to all the other dimensions so
here she goes y'all notice who's using
her fur moves and our animation just
like we do in the movie she doesn't Bend
in the way that the Lego video game
characters do she's the worst blended of
banks from the movie and now we've got
an example of the sort of portal
interaction that you'll be able to do so
what's happening here is their message
is flashing up telling you to place
wildstar the master builder character
into the central area of the toy pack
there are three areas the central area
there will mean that she's now got just
taken over those bricks in the mill and
now she's able to take over the bricks
on the right as we move in I'm gonna
move her again onto the Left which will
take those three bricks and now she's
able to build them into what will become
how a gateway and this is what I was
saying you get the actual instructions
up here now I've got the bricks here but
again because I love shaking them it's a
fantastic hands-on feelings of business
sheer sort of pleasure of handling the
bricks and then spinning it together and
snapping them together and bringing that
to match the virtual experience of
puzzle solving it's something that we've
never dreamt of being able to do before
and we're so thrilled with it and it
looks like it's asking you to
build the Batmobile now Sarah yeah
that's right it's good a vehicle in so
we've been playing with these we're
playing with these characters but I also
mentioned that you can put in vehicles
and accessories here's the first one
this is with the starter pack of the
Batmobile of course any character could
ride in the vehicles or control the
Velociraptor or the sentry turret or the
exoskeletons everything you can build so
let's build build about the vales and
then we're going to write to the toy tag
because we build the battle bill and as
I mentioned alien you can rebuild it in
two different vehicles I will drive
analyzer Leo Mazzone the Batmobile
fantastic plan he's going to use this
device here the power the Batmobile to
actually give it energy into the Gateway
that's going to take us into the
different leg of the missions that's
good enables our our adventure
characters to go and embark on what will
be the first level of the story which is
actually the Wizard of Oz the way we've
decided which dimensions we want to go
into by picking out many of our favorite
worlds we've always been privileged to
be able to play with the world's
favorite characters and stories and to
be able to bring them together in this
one it was just a case of thinking you
know where we wanted to go let's go -
we've had great fun in Gotham City
before and a decent universe let's let's
explore that but also let's go to new
places we've never been to before like
the world of The Simpsons or the world
of pork as well and you've got some it's
got a good mix of you know more than
newer franchise's kid-friendly
franchises like you know Ninjago and
Chima sure and also he has some of the
older ones that would appeal to you know
like parents or like you mentioned
ghostbusters and back to the future now
how important was it to you know to get
some of those older franchises in to you
know get that Chairman fire as well so
it was really really important to go
places that people wouldn't expect and
places that only do they go could go to
as well I think you're actually right
it's the bringing together of those
where a parent can be excited something
remember and then share that feeling
that thrill on a pleasure with you know
someone who's new to that this was
probably going to be the first
experience that term that some children
have off of ghostbusters post being a
doctor who quite possibly of here we are
in but now we've Homer so we can put the
familiar and the unfamiliar together so
you can mix and match anyone in any of
those yeah that's my hope let's put
someone else in let's take out Homer
okay and that's put in I see yes we got
Shellhead yeah yeah show they have a
portal with her portal gum and she can
come in how does it work so we'll just
demonstrate here and in the portal level
you can use the power of the toy pad to
open up riffs which will enable you to
move between spaces we have no issues
you can mix and match than any of these
like synced in this campaigns as a yep
absolutely and it you know you don't
even have to hurt the toes to buy own
the characters you can come round to a
friend's house take your characters
drawn want to type that not only will
that enable those characters to appear
in the story but you can then once
you've got a character unlock their
adventure as well aren't any characters
essential like will you'd me Gandalf and
wyldstyle any Batman throughout the
entire campaign Gandalf Ammon and whilst
I will get you through the campaign and
then able to unlock all the trophies but
they're in the game it's their story
that's told in the cutscenes but you can
put in other characters
so we're using some of the different
character powers here Batman's using his
grapple hook and we've got a puzzle up
ahead here where the poppies are going
to send him to sleep that's we're gonna
have to find some way to get through
this bag and wake him up first of all by
pounding that circle button and then
find a vehicle dropping we could drop
him with a Batmobile but he quits not
just the characters we can drop them
with we could put in a velociraptor
grotto is a vehicle
yeah the lot structures a vehicle I'm
gonna test this out national surely I'm
now experimenting life the Velociraptor
going to go through the poppies all the
basarat go to sleep well I've also she's
not strong in it not not powerful enough
he's gonna Sally could is that he or she
she is this clever girl isn't it
because she is is alive she's also
affected by the character soporific
effect of the poppies citizens car Oh
Simpsons car okay
driven now Batman you need to have an
open-top car it's not the right he's
used to will enable you to smash right
through those so thank you for showing
us Lego dimensions Jonathan I know it's
out real soon can you tell us some when
it's out and what platform has done you
know of course Lego dimensions is out on
September the 27th real soon and it's
out on Xbox one PlayStation 4
PlayStation 3 Xbox 360 and Wii U so
there's no excuse not playing Lego
donations and that's not if as well
right because you'll have more packs and
more characters coming out as the month
progresses that correct yeah this is
this is a platform for us so the toy hub
that you buy from the startin that
you've built will enable you to play
with all future characters that we
release so we have a fantastic range
available to start your great character
the starter pack lots of characters from
the start in fun packs and level packs
but we're gonna releasing more over the
years ahead and they will all work with
that base ok thank you very much John
this man thank you
he's brainless I much still overskirt
why is it Toto again